mọi người có công nhận là làm con gái thiệt mệt hông
bao nhiêu thứ phải chăm lo
giữ gìn hàng ngày á thì mẹ dặn Ra đường là quần áo
đầu tóc phải chỉn Chu
tới tháng
thì sức cùng lực kiệt rồi mà vẫn phải chăm sóc Cho làm SAO
không chỉ là cơ thể nha mà còn cái chỗ
ấy nó cũng phải thơm tho sạch sẽ
Cho nên video này với tư cách là một người chị
một người bạn thậm chí là một người em
Vinh sẽ chia sẻ hết với mọi người Chi tiết
từng bước
cũng như là những cái sản phẩm mà mình sử dụng để chăm
chút từng cái thứ nhỏ nhất ở trên cơ thể
giúp Cho cái công cuộc làm con gái của mình nó không có
thiệt mệt nữa mà nó phải
thật là tuyệt nha
mình sẽ chia video này làm 2 phần lớn nha
thứ nhất sẽ là những cái món mà Trinh sử dụng
trong những cái a ngày tháng gọi là
Chu kỳ của phụ nữ đó
và tới cái phần thứ 2
thì sẽ là những cái thứ mà Trinh sử dụng hàng ngày
thậm chí là hàng giờ
trong mỗi phần á thì cũng sẽ có những cái sản phẩm gọi là
cơ bản mình không thể sống thiếu
nhưng mà bên cạnh đó cũng sẽ có những cái thứ gọi là extra
nếu mà mình hông có thì cũng được nhưng
mà nếu mà có thì nó sẽ giúp Cho mình
nâng tầm chất lượng cuộc sống của mình hơn
nhưng mà mọi người cũng lưu ý là
để tránh Cho cái video này nó quá dài
á thì Trinh cũng chỉ nêu Ra những cái sản phẩm mà mình
đắt nhất thôi
Cho nên là ở cái bước nào mà mọi người muốn Trinh chia sẻ
Chi tiết hơn á thì mọi người để lại comment bên dưới
mình sẽ tách Ra
làm riêng một cái chủ đề video khác chẳng hạn